toute ma vie je me suis culpabilisée de
me dire je suis pas comme les autres je
suis pas comme il faut je suis gênante
socialement les gens me trouvent bizarre
et toute la toute ma vie je me suis dit
pourquoi je fais ça pourquoi j'y arrive
pas parce que moi j'étais autopersuadé
que c'était de ma faute parce que toute
ma vie c'était en mode mais tu fais
exprès c'est toi tu fais exprès même les
profs même tout le monde so la
différence c'est quelque chose qu'on
rejette beaucoup au début quand on quand
on pense l'être dès que je sors de chez
moi il faut un peu prendre mon courage à
demain ça passe par des moments où du
coup j'ai plus aucune tolérance pour
rien et et tout va être dur et tout va
être une épreuve elle m'a demandé mais
ça va les relations sociales juste comme
ça et en fait moi j'avais pas remarqué
que ça allait pas quand j'ai eu mon
diagnostic je me suis dit ah ok c'est
pas de ma faute c'est pas moi en fait ça
s'explique il y a une explication je me
suis dit ok ben très bien en fait j'ai
d'autres caractéristiques qui qui que
les autres n'ont pas et qui sont des
forces donc j'ai plus vu ça comme juste
une faiblesse et comme un truc
culpabilisant j'ai vu ça comme une
fatalité de me dire ok c'est cool j'ai
une explication et maintenant je vais
essayer de me renseigner pour trouver
mes forces et je vais essayer d'en faire
quelque chose de chouette ce qui m'a mis
la puce à l'oreille c'est quand j'ai vu
que c'était un trouble qui s'exprime
différemment chez les hommes et chez les
femmes les filles vont peut-être plus
cacher leur différence vont peut-être
plus vouloir se fondre dans le moule
c'est tout ce qui fait le handicap
invisible c'est-à-dire que c'est pas
parce que visiblement ça semble fin ça
semble pas se voir qu'intérieurement
c'est pas plus difficile à vivre et que
ça pas big à l'intérieur je sais pas
quel âge vous avez V diagnostique je
sais que parfois quand on est plus jeune
c'est plus compliqué à vivre mais en
fait souvent je pense que quand on la
tarte c'est souvent une un soulagement
pour moi ça a été le cas et ça a
vraiment tout changé en fait moi je suis
arrivé à un point je pense comme
peut-être certaines autres personnes où
je suis plus fier en fait d' différent
que les autres et cette différence en
fait me fait moi en fait me rend unique
je sais que si j'avais pas ce
diagnostique pas le trouble autistique
je pense pas que j'aurais fait ce métier
et je pense pas que non plus que
j'aurais cet humour là que j'aurais
cette ce regard sur les choses cette
façon de s'ans filtre de de parler donc
clairement aujourd'hui c'est c'est c'est
vraiment une force et je pense que c'est
vraiment ma différence qui fait aussi
mon mon succès et comment j'ai orienté
ma ma
carrière je vous
comprends